[MUSIC]
So also is a change model that I share
with organizations that are going
through devops transformation.
In that change model we
begin with an event,
we do something in the organization
that is new or different.
This could be the automation
of infrastructure,
it could be automated test coverage,
it could be any number of things that
we do to improve our release practice.
On the basis of that event,
we have new language now.
So often what you get from the
organization is that we can't do X or
Y, that's not possible.
And so as the change agent,
as the devops engineer inside of your
organization, you then go and do this
thing that was that had previously
been believed to be impossible.
And now we have new language
in the organization.
Even if the language had been no prior,
now the language is [LAUGH] Okay I
guess that is a thing we could do.
>From that perspective now,
structure inside the organization
begins to give way.
And as that does, you have more agency,
more flexibility,
more freedom to act in that space.
And so you have Event,
Language, Structure, Agency.